to grow a tropical rainforest in the
cornwall chill
takes some energy and in the search for
a sustainable source of heat the eden
project
is going underground this 450 ton
drill is boring nearly three miles into
the earth's crust
in search of hot rocks water that's
pumped down then brought to the surface
again
could be superheated to 180 degrees
that's enough to generate all the
electricity and heat that eden needs
plus more for thousands of local homes
it is going to provide base load which
is the holy grail of energy
the argument from those who were
anti-renewables
was when the wind don't blow and the sun
don't shine you've got a problem
now you haven't this will provide you
energy 24 7
when you want it to fill in for all the
other energy sources so it's a
a wonderful triumvirate of power sources
geothermal energy could be tapped across
large areas of the uk
north and south the rocks are hot enough
in some parts to supply 20
of the total uk electricity demand
elsewhere
even slightly cooler areas could heat
every home
and business in the country it's taken
10 years and 17 million pounds to get
this drill in the ground
and it is that enormous upfront cost
that has been the major deterrent
to geothermal here in the uk but the
people behind this project believe they
can produce energy
for the same price as gas but without
the carbon
it's all about incentives and innovation
says the president of this year's
climate change conference
who got the hard sell on a walk around
the site at one point of course
uh you know offshore wind was quite
expensive to generate and yet
because we supported it through the
contracts for different auction
processes
at the next round of course of later on
this year we've managed to build the
biggest
offshore wind sector in the world so if
you're creating revenue mechanisms it is
possible for new industries to come
through
there is still risk in geothermal until
the drill has done its work in five
months time
eden's engineers can't be certain they
can extract
enough hot water but if it does work as
well as they hope
the site will be carbon negative in just
two years
thomas more sky news in cornwall